Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Does Magna Carta mean nothing to you? Did she die in vain? Brave Hungarian peasant girl who forced King John to sign the pledge at Runnymede and close the boozes at half past ten? Is all this to be forgotten? The wise words of Antony Aloysius Hancock in Hancock's Half Hour,
感谢收听《历史余温》。想要获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。《大宪章》对你来说毫无意义吗？她难道是白白牺牲的吗？那位勇敢的匈牙利农家女孩，强迫约翰王在兰尼米德签署誓约，并在十点半关掉酒吧？这一切都要被遗忘吗？安东尼·阿洛伊修斯·汉考克在《汉考克半小时》中的睿智名言，
Twelve Angry Men. Welcome to The Rest is History. As always, we take our cues from the comedies of the 1950s. And today we are talking about Magna Carta, King John, the document that supposedly enshrines the liberties of every freeborn Englishman. Tom Holland, you're a big Magna Carta fan, no doubt. I am quite a fan of Magna Carta, which I feel is quite an unfashionable thing to be really, because my sense of reading historians on it is that they can sometimes kind of downplay it. They laugh at Magna Carta. They do laugh at Magna Carta. And that's why I think we've brought on, we've got as our guest, a historian who...
《十二怒汉》。欢迎收听《历史余温》。像往常一样，我们从20世纪50年代的喜剧中寻找灵感。今天我们要谈论的是《大宪章》、约翰王，以及那份据称保障了每一位英格兰自由民权利的文件。汤姆·霍兰，毫无疑问，你是《大宪章》的忠实粉丝。我确实是《大宪章》的粉丝，我觉得这在当下其实相当不合时宜，因为据我阅读历史学家的观点来看，他们有时会淡化它的重要性。他们嘲笑《大宪章》。他们确实嘲笑《大宪章》。这就是为什么我认为我们请来了一位历史学家作为嘉宾，他……
He's going to laugh at it for us. Well, no. He ran a website called Magna Carta Balls, which may well imply his view on it. And that is the one and only Ted Vallance, professor of history at Roehampton, author of A Radical History of Britain, a 17th century specialist currently working on a book on the trial of Charles I. So not a fan of dodgy monarchs. Ted, are you a fan of John? No, and I think very few people were or are. I mean, I think he's just one of those monarchs who, I mean, maybe there is a revisionist biography of King John about to come out that I don't know about, but it seems like he's got a pretty bad press from his day until the present.
他会替我们嘲笑它。好吧，不。他曾经营一个名为“大宪章胡扯”（Magna Carta Balls）的网站，这很可能暗示了他对它的看法。他就是独一无二的泰德·瓦伦斯，罗汉普顿大学历史学教授，《英国激进史》作者，17世纪研究专家，目前正在撰写一本关于查理一世审判的书。所以他不是那种不可靠君主的粉丝。泰德，你是约翰王的粉丝吗？不，我想很少有人是，或者曾经是。我的意思是，我觉得他就是那种君主，也许有一本关于约翰王的修正主义传记即将出版而我不知道，但从他那个时代到现在，他的名声似乎一直很差。
As Sellers and Eatman put it in 1066 and all that, he's our first memorable wicked uncle in English history. And I think that reputation has kind of stayed with him. Tom Holland, two weeks ago, presented a rousing defence of the Emperor Nero as an uxorious, clean-living, chariot-racing... I didn't say he was clean-living. Renaissance man. You did say he was uxorious.
正如塞勒斯和伊特曼在《1066年及其以后》中所说，他是我们英国历史上第一个令人难忘的邪恶叔叔。我认为这种名声一直伴随着他。汤姆·霍兰，两周前，对尼禄皇帝进行了一番激昂的辩护，称他是一位宠爱妻子、生活检点、热衷赛车的……我没说他生活检点。文艺复兴式的人物。你确实说了他宠爱妻子。
I did, yes, well, he was. I would be astounded if you haven't come into this podcast arm-tooled up for a defence of King John. Am I right? Well, I think we should put him first of all in his historical context shouldn't we before we come on to so he's playing just how bad he was so yeah so he's so so dominic give us a a quick skim description of him um that's put me on the spot so it's okay oh sorry no no i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it. Do you think I'm not tooled up because I am? Well, I just suddenly realised it was implied because we've got Ted here. Well, Ted, do you know King John's dates off the top of your head?
我说了，是的，好吧，他确实是。如果你不是带着为约翰王辩护的准备来参加这期播客，我会感到非常惊讶。我说对了吗？嗯，我认为我们首先应该把他放在历史背景中，不是吗？在我们开始讨论他有多糟糕之前，所以，多米尼克，给我们一个快速的概述吧，嗯，你让我措手不及，没关系，哦抱歉，不，不，我要说，我要说。你觉得我没有准备好吗？因为我准备好了。好吧，我只是突然意识到这是一种暗示，因为我们请来了泰德。好吧，泰德，你知道约翰王的生卒年吗？
No. Professor of History at Roehampton. Striking it hard there. 1199. 1199 is 1216. Are you reading that off a piece of paper? He succeeds Richard the Lionheart. He loses Normandy.
不知道。罗汉普顿大学历史学教授。这下尴尬了。1199年。1199年到1216年。你是从纸上读出来的吗？他继承了狮心王理查。他失去了诺曼底。
So he's only king for 17 years. But Ted and I were once colleagues together at the University of Sheffield, and we had a colleague who was a medieval historian who appeared on a Channel 5 documentary series talking about King John, and it was called The Most Evil Men in History. And the people on this series were Stalin, Hitler, Pol Pot, and King John. And I think that was kind of harsh because as far as I understand it, John was a poor king and a weak king, and he sort of squeezed people for money,
所以他只当了17年国王。但泰德和我曾经是谢菲尔德大学的同事，我们有一位同事是中世纪历史学家，他曾出现在第五频道的一部纪录片系列中谈论约翰王，片名叫做《历史上最邪恶的人》。这个系列里的人包括斯大林、希特勒、波尔布特和约翰王。我觉得这有点苛刻，因为据我所知，约翰是一个糟糕的国王，一个软弱的国王，他为了钱压榨人民，
and he lost battles. But to call him evil is probably a bit – I mean, it's not Pol Pot. I think we can probably – yeah, I think in comparison to Pol Pot, probably, yeah, he's, you know, we're being a bit harsh on him by comparing him to genocidal 20th century dictators. Yeah, and I think sort of, I mean, probably if we're, you know, we're trying to be fair to John, I would say that he is a tyrant in the classical sense, in that he's somebody who rules according to his will and what he wants to get done.
而且他输掉了战争。但称他为邪恶可能有点——我的意思是，他不是波尔布特。我想我们大概可以——是的，我认为与波尔布特相比，可能，是的，你知道，我们将他与20世纪的种族灭绝独裁者相提并论，对他有点太苛刻了。是的，而且我认为，如果我们试图对约翰公平一点，我会说他在古典意义上是一个暴君，因为他是一个按照自己的意志和想要实现的目标来统治的人。
And so he does things like, you know, imprison members of the family of people who aren't paying him taxes and starves them to death. You know, he's not a nice guy from that perspective. Because that was a mother and her son, wasn't it? Yes. In Corfe Castle. And when their corpses were found, it turned out that the mother had eaten the cheek of her son. I mean, that's pretty evil.
所以他会做一些事情，比如，你知道，监禁那些不给他交税的人的家人，并让他们饿死。你知道，从这个角度来看，他不是个好人。因为那是一位母亲和她的儿子，对吧？是的。在科夫城堡。当他们的尸体被发现时，结果发现那位母亲吃了她儿子的脸颊。我的意思是，这相当邪恶。
But, Tom, you could argue that's the mother at fault rather than King John. Can you? Well, I know. I think if you're peckish, you know, you haven't got anything else to eat. If you're applying the same standards you'd apply to Nero. Nero never, I mean, Nero killed his mother,
但是，汤姆，你可以争辩说那是母亲的错，而不是约翰王的错。可以吗？嗯，我知道。我想如果你饿了，你知道，你没有别的东西可吃。如果你用对待尼禄的标准来衡量他。尼禄从来没有，我的意思是，尼禄杀了他母亲，
but he didn't eat her. So that's my case. He's still, yeah. But I mean, John's problem. I mean, I think, so the judgment of John Gillingham, Emeritus Professor of Medieval History at the London School of Economics and Political Science, he was a shit. And I think that's true.
但他没有吃她。所以这就是我的论点。他仍然是，是的。但我的意思是，约翰的问题。我的意思是，我认为，伦敦政治经济学院中世纪历史名誉教授约翰·吉林厄姆的评价是，他是个混蛋。我认为这是真的。
He was clearly a very, very unpleasant man. I mean, he had this horrible habit of, say, William Marshall, the great knight errant, the greatest knight of his day, who stands by John through thick and thin. John would go up to William Marshall and kind of tell him that his best friends had died in distant battles. And it would be completely made up. It would just be done to kind of get a rise out of him. So that's a kind of genuinely horrible thing to do. Sort of jackass approach to kingship, is it? That he's having to raise money because of the one
他显然是一个非常、非常令人不快的人。我的意思是，他有一种可怕的习惯，比如，威廉·马歇尔，那位伟大的游侠骑士，他那个时代最伟大的骑士，一直坚定地支持约翰。约翰会走到威廉·马歇尔面前，告诉他他最好的朋友在遥远的战斗中阵亡了。而这完全是编造的。这只是为了激怒他。所以这是一种真正可怕的行为。这是一种对待王权的混蛋方式，是吗？他不得不筹钱，因为他统治期间的唯一
catastrophe of his reign which is losing this great empire in france that he's inherited from well ultimately from william the conqueror who's the duke of normandy conquers england of course but then the accumulation of other um territories that he's got from his father henry ii and which his brother the great crusader richard the Lionheart had defended so heroically. And then John just loses the lot. And so then he is spending the rest of his reign, essentially screwing money out of England, this great milch cow to try and raise cash. He does that. He launches an invasion attempt on France to get his territories back. And then at this battle at Bavine in 1214, he loses. And that's a judgment both on him as a tactician, as a commander,
灾难，就是失去了他从威廉一世那里继承的法国大帝国，威廉一世是诺曼底公爵，当然征服了英格兰，但随后又积累了从他父亲亨利二世那里得到的其他领土，而他的兄弟，伟大的十字军战士狮心王理查曾英勇地保卫过这些领土。然后约翰把一切都输光了。所以他统治的余生基本上都在从英格兰榨钱，把这当成一头巨大的奶牛来筹集现金。他做到了。他发动了对法国的入侵试图夺回领土。然后在1214年的布汶战役中，他输了。这既是对他作为战术家、指挥官的审判，
but also a judgment on him coming from God, because clearly God has judged him and found him wanting. And basically everything follows from that, doesn't it? I mean, that's what Magna Carta is about, is that he's been so oppressive. He's now, after Bavine, having to raise more money, and people just can't face it yeah i think it's it that's totally that the context is totally this this ratcheting up of taxation you know six times the level uh at the start of his reign uh and the pressure of that
也是来自上帝对他的审判，因为显然上帝已经审判了他并认为他不够格。基本上一切都由此而来，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是《大宪章》的意义所在，他一直如此压迫。在布汶战役之后，他现在不得不筹集更多的钱，而人们只是无法面对它。是的，我认为这完全是，背景完全是这种税收的不断加码，你知道，是他统治初期的六倍，这种压力
becomes um you know something that the english elite are no longer prepared to bear, particularly in light of the military disaster that has befallen John and the loss of those lands. And that is the context in which this document, Magna Carta, is created of effectively a civil war with, you know, the rebel barons basically, you know, deciding that they are going to resist the heavy burden of taxation that's placed upon them and forced John by force of arms to the negotiating table. And that's where we get to with Magna Carta in June of 1215. And Ted, is that something that's completely unprecedented? So in other words, is this the first time a king has signed up to anything
变得……你知道，英格兰精英阶层不再准备忍受，特别是在约翰遭遇军事灾难和失去那些土地的情况下。这就是《大宪章》这份文件产生的背景，实际上是一场内战，你知道，叛乱的男爵们基本上决定，他们要抵制强加在他们身上的沉重税收负担，并以武力迫使约翰坐到谈判桌前。这就是我们在1215年6月得到《大宪章》的原因。泰德，这是完全史无前例的吗？换句话说，这是国王第一次签署任何东西
to limit his own power, or have there been sort of instances of this before? So I think when historians are sort of thinking about this and looking at this in a sort of broader European context, I mean, there have been arguments that there are kind of similar sorts of aristocratic charters that sort of place similar kinds of burdens on monarchy. I think the argument has been that Magna Carta is exceptional because of its breadth and because it seems to go much beyond just being a kind of set of aristocratic demands and includes these broader principles. And I think some of the most
来限制他自己的权力，还是之前有过类似的例子？所以我认为当历史学家在思考这个问题并从更广阔的欧洲背景来看待它时，我的意思是，有人争辩说存在类似的贵族宪章，对君主制施加了类似的负担。我认为争论的焦点在于《大宪章》的特殊性在于它的广度，因为它似乎不仅仅是一套贵族要求，还包含了这些更广泛的原则。我认为一些最
interesting work has actually been to say that, in fact, those kinds of principles about the binding nature of agreements on royal power are actually things that are accepted across Western Europe as well, that you can find kind of imperial judgments from a century or more prior to Magna Carta, which basically say that the king can't just tear up, you know, agreements that are made and seize property and tax people. There has to be a process of law. And actually, that sort of idea of judgment by your peers, which obviously, you know, literally kind of, you know, fellow nobles is something that's a kind of Europe wide principle that's being observed and adhered to so it's not the necessarily the
有趣的研究实际上是在说，事实上，关于皇家权力协议约束力的原则实际上在西欧也是被接受的，你可以找到在《大宪章》之前一个世纪或更早的帝国判决，它们基本上说国王不能仅仅撕毁达成的协议，没收财产和向人民征税。必须有一个法律程序。实际上，那种由同侪审判的想法，显然，你知道，字面上就是同僚贵族，是一种在欧洲范围内被观察和遵守的原则，所以它不一定是
first in terms of statements these principles but it is the kind of scope of it the scale of it which is unusual which actually connects back to you know what tom was talking about in terms of the way in which you know we might see magna Carta as a product of a tax revolt which is basically that John is kind of looking at so many different tax loopholes and trying to sort of screw money out of so many different areas that it is just this kind of comprehensive suite of things that the king can't do you know he can't fiddle with inheritance in this way or wards in this way or you know forests all these different things he can't do um the charges say you have to be kind of hived off and protected basically because one of the things one of john's qualities that you
在陈述这些原则方面是第一个，但它的范围和规模是不寻常的，这实际上与汤姆所说的联系起来了，即我们可能将《大宪章》视为税收反抗的产物，基本上就是约翰在寻找各种不同的税收漏洞，并试图从这么多不同的领域榨钱，以至于它只是国王不能做的事情的全面集合，你知道，他不能以这种方式篡改继承权，或者以这种方式对待监护权，或者你知道，森林，所有这些不同的事情他都不能做，嗯，这些条款说你必须被隔离和保护，基本上是因为约翰的品质之一，你
could emphasize would be precisely that he does have this incredible command of detail and you know if there's a chance to make money he will sniff it out and come after you and that's precisely why magna carta has to be so detailed is because they want to block everything off and because they don't trust him an inch. But also, I mean, John is brought to the negotiating table essentially because by 1215 there's a stalemate. And what brings the stalemate really round is that his enemies capture London. And without London, John can't win. But equally, John has an army, he has mercenaries, he has everything, he has all his castles. So the bar John can't win. But equally, John has an army, has mercenaries, has everything, has all his castles. So the barons can't win.
可以强调的正是他确实拥有这种令人难以置信的细节掌控力，而且你知道，如果有赚钱的机会，他会嗅出来并追着你，这正是《大宪章》必须如此详细的原因，因为他们想封锁一切，因为他们一点也不信任他。但同时，我的意思是，约翰被带到谈判桌前，基本上是因为到1215年出现了僵局。真正打破僵局的是他的敌人占领了伦敦。没有伦敦，约翰就赢不了。但同样，约翰有军队，他有雇佣兵，他有一切，他有他所有的城堡。所以男爵们赢不了。
So they decide to meet. I mean, Windsor is basically kind of neutral ground. I suppose John's got a huge castle at Windsor. But they meet at Runnymede, which is meadows, open space. And they meet on an island in the middle of the thames and that's the measure of how little trust there is between both sides yeah and both camps are armed as well and they are as you say effectively meeting somewhere that is you know near to where you know near to london but not in london which is now held by the rebels so it's sort of a a relatively safe neutral zone but one in which obviously
所以他们决定会面。我的意思是，温莎基本上是中立地带。我想约翰在温莎有一座巨大的城堡。但他们在兰尼米德会面，那是草地，开放空间。他们在泰晤士河中间的一个岛上会面，这就是双方之间缺乏信任程度的衡量标准。是的，而且两个阵营都全副武装，正如你所说，他们实际上是在一个靠近伦敦但不在伦敦的地方会面，而伦敦现在被叛军控制，所以这是一种相对安全的缓冲区，但显然
neither side trusts the other enough to come unarmed to this to this meeting have you have you heard of the anchor wiki you i have not heard of the anchor wiki i'm dying to know more well i bring i mentioned just because my uh friend jamie muir ted who you know yes we've all done pub quizzes together he he took me on a tour of his um places where he grew up and the anchorwick u is a u next to saint mary's priory in runnymede and apparently it was on an island isn't anymore very very ancient and the theory is is that this is where john set the seal on magna carta which is a highly contested, but I just throw that in because it's a kind of interesting detail. Ted, to move on from Tom's fascinating detail.
双方都不信任对方，以至于不敢不带武器参加这次会议。你听说过安克威克紫杉吗？我没听说过安克威克紫杉，我渴望了解更多。好吧，我提到它只是因为我的朋友杰米·缪尔，泰德，你认识的，是的，我们都一起参加过酒吧问答，他带我参观了他长大的地方，安克威克紫杉是兰尼米德圣玛丽修道院旁边的一棵紫杉，显然它曾经在一个岛上，现在不是了，非常非常古老，理论上这就是约翰在《大宪章》上盖章的地方，这是一个极具争议的说法，但我只是把它抛出来，因为它是一个有趣的细节。泰德，从汤姆迷人的细节中继续前进。
So they're there. They've got their soldiers with them. There's the barons. There's John and his cronies. How much is this basically a purely kind of internal elite matter that these are just people from this sort of top caste of society and no one else could give two hoots um i mean i think there's one sort of if you like jaundiced view of magna carta which is just you know um and and tom has brought up my magna carta balls history which is just to say this is
所以他们在那儿。他们带着士兵。有男爵们。有约翰和他的亲信。这在多大程度上基本上是一个纯粹的内部精英事务，即这些人只是来自社会顶层，而其他人根本不在乎？嗯，我想有一种对《大宪章》的冷眼旁观，就是，你知道，汤姆提到了我的“大宪章胡扯”历史，这只是说这是
you know very squabbling amongst various rich people, you know, a series of demands from the top 1% for tax exemption. You know, we could view it in that way. But I think most of the experts on the period actually argue that there is more going on here, that there is something more broad ranging and substantive about sort of rights and liberties that's being articulated and i think actually that's one of the things that um susan reynolds and her in her piece on sort of you know the european context of magna carta stresses is that when the barons are talking about things like judgment of peers, they are engaging with these broader kind of agreed principles that are there. And Ted, the guy who's basically the umpire, the guy who's kind of convening this conference, Stephen Langton, Archbishop of Canterbury, former professor at Paris, University of Paris.
你知道，各种富人之间的争吵，你知道，来自前1%的免税要求。你知道，我们可以这样看。但我认为该领域的大多数专家实际上认为这里发生的事情更多，关于某种权利和自由，有一些更广泛和实质性的东西正在被阐述，我认为实际上这就是苏珊·雷诺兹在关于《大宪章》欧洲背景的文章中强调的一点，即当男爵们谈论同侪审判之类的事情时，他们正在与那些更广泛的、已达成的原则进行互动。泰德，那个基本上是裁判的人，那个召集这次会议的人，斯蒂芬·朗顿，坎特伯雷大主教，前巴黎大学教授。
John's had an enormous run in with the pope about whether to let him in or not um basically john's kind of submitted to the pope and let him in um how key is his role because obviously he's he's not a neutral operator he's there to defend the interests of the church right yeah and i think you know the position of the church and the papacy is important as well because both sides are actually trying to get this external, you know, approval on their actions from the papacy in these negotiations as well. So both the rebels and John, John, who's previously been excommunicated for his failure to recognise Stephen Langton as well, is trying to now get Innocent III on side to get him on his side. Because Innocent III is a Pope of kind of enormous sweep isn't it and that's an
约翰在是否让他入境的问题上与教皇发生了巨大的冲突，嗯，基本上约翰向教皇屈服并让他进来了，他的角色有多关键？因为显然他不是一个中立的操作者，他在那里是为了捍卫教会的利益，对吧？是的，而且我认为你知道，教会和教廷的立场也很重要，因为双方实际上都在这些谈判中试图从教廷那里获得对其行动的外部批准。所以叛军和约翰，约翰，他之前因为未能承认斯蒂芬·朗顿而被逐出教会，现在正试图让英诺森三世站在他这一边。因为英诺森三世是一位拥有巨大影响力的教皇，不是吗？这是一个
example of how in a way unlucky John is that he's up against a Pope who really is in a position to kind of humble kings. Yeah and also that it's not just you know this is not just an English elite concern it's a concern that obviously you know connects with France as well as with the papacy. And so John is not just, you know, dealing with these English barons. He's dealing with these other forces as well and trying to negotiate with these other external forces too. And of course, the rights of the church also become an important part of, you know, the discussions within the charter um and that's actually you know one of the one of the you know the clauses of the charter that remains
例子，说明约翰在某种程度上是多么不幸，他面对的是一位真正有能力让国王谦卑的教皇。是的，而且这不仅仅是英格兰精英的担忧，这显然也与法国以及教廷有关。所以约翰不仅是在处理这些英格兰男爵。他也在处理这些其他力量，并试图与这些外部力量进行谈判。当然，教会的权利也成为宪章内讨论的重要部分，
in legal force today is the one that protects your notionally protects the rights of the church could could would it be very boring or would it be very interesting i think the answer is always it's very boring if i just very quickly skimmed through what magna carta says well it'd be good to know what it says yeah yeah so i've got i've got david carpenter's edition for the penguin classics came out obviously in 2015 for the anniversary yeah uh very good edition and so it kicks off with john by the grace of god king of england lord of ireland blah blah blah blah and then you get a list of all the people the witnesses and it's the churchmen who come first so stephen langton archbishop of dublin
而这实际上是宪章中至今仍然具有法律效力的条款之一，即保护教会权利的条款。如果我只是非常快速地浏览一下《大宪章》的内容，会很无聊还是很有趣？我想答案总是很无聊。所以，我手头有大卫·卡彭特为企鹅经典版编辑的版本，显然是2015年周年纪念版出的，非常好的版本。它以“约翰，蒙上帝恩典，英格兰国王，爱尔兰领主，等等等等”开头，然后你得到了一份所有见证人的名单，首先是教会人士，比如斯蒂芬·朗顿，都柏林大主教，
papal envoy etc and then you get a list of all the kind of noblemen so that's how it kicks off and as ted as you said the very first so this has been divided up into chapters i think later on isn't it it's some later jurist who does this so it's not actually in the documents but the very first one is saying the English church should be free. And so that's still on the statute book. That's one of the things. Then you get loads of stuff about basically the barons trying to stop John from raising money in sneaky ways.
教皇特使等等，然后你得到了一份所有贵族的名单，这就是它的开头。正如泰德你所说，第一条……这后来被分成了章节，不是吗？是一些后来的法学家做的，所以它实际上不在文件中，但第一条是说英格兰教会应该是自由的。所以这仍然在法典中。这是其中之一。然后你得到大量关于男爵们试图阻止约翰以卑鄙方式筹钱的内容。
And you just get loads and loads of them. And it's all about the widows. This is all the inheritance stuff, isn't it? And, yeah, widows. Yeah. You can't charge you to marry this person or whatever. Widows and lords and, yeah. And Jews. So Jews are the moneylenders. Yeah.
你得到了一大堆。这全是关于寡妇的，这是所有的继承权问题，对吧？是的，寡妇。是的。你不能收费让你嫁给这个人或什么的。寡妇和领主，是的。还有犹太人。所以犹太人是放债人。是的。
And John is, you know, kind of exploiting them to get cash. So he's trying to reign. Oh, and London. So London is, you know, it's siding with the barons. And the city of London is to have all its ancient liberties and free customs by both land and water so that's still in force that's still in force as well so importantly obviously preserve the city of london and i think london is the only town mentioned in magna carta so that's a kind of reflection of its importance uh then just you know loads of stuff uh then you start getting mentions of um uh people. So no one is to be restrained to build bridges at riverbanks.
约翰在利用他们来获取现金。所以他试图统治。哦，还有伦敦。所以伦敦站在男爵一边。伦敦城应拥有其所有古老的自由和自由习惯，无论是陆地还是水路，所以这仍然有效，这仍然有效。所以重要的是显然要保护伦敦城，我认为伦敦是《大宪章》中提到的唯一城镇，所以这是对其重要性的一种反映。然后只是，你知道，一大堆东西，然后你开始看到关于……人的提及。所以没有人应该被限制在河岸上建造桥梁。
So I guess that's not on the statute book. But I mean, that's something perhaps if we have to start building bridges for Boris over the Irish Sea or something. This is actually what sounds like a very minor one. But Susan Reynolds points out that it's quite an interesting one in terms of the broader implications, because that one is basically saying that, you know, it's one that's even dealing with the rights of the unfree it's saying you can't you know get get your villains to to build bridges or whatever so it's actually it's actually you know as as boring and sort of irrelevant to our interests as it seems now it's maybe one that actually says some interesting things about the broader implications
所以我猜那不在法典中。但我的意思是，如果我们要开始为鲍里斯在爱尔兰海或其他地方建造桥梁，这也许是某种东西。这听起来确实是一个非常小的条款。但苏珊·雷诺兹指出，从更广泛的含义来看，这是一个相当有趣的条款，因为那一条基本上是在说，你知道，它甚至涉及到了不自由者的权利，它说你不能让你的农奴去建造桥梁或什么的，所以它实际上，正如它现在看起来那样无聊和与我们的利益无关，它也许是真正说明了一些关于更广泛含义的有趣事情。
so hold on is this a world in which in which you were at risk if you sort of, you know, a sunny day, you're wandering down the lane, of being press-ganged into building a bridge at a moment's notice? Absolutely, yeah. It was a common anxiety of the labouring poor of the time. Or it seems of having someone nick your horse or cart, because that's also banned. So there's this kind of idea that John could just just nick your car that's important oh and wood neither we nor our bailiff shall take wood
等等，这是一个如果你在阳光明媚的日子里沿着小路漫步，就有可能被强征去临时建造桥梁的世界吗？绝对是，是的。这是当时劳动贫民的普遍焦虑。或者看起来是有人偷你的马或马车，因为那也被禁止了。所以有一种想法，约翰可以随便偷你的车，这很重要。哦，还有木材，我们和我们的法警不得为了城堡而拿走属于他人的木材，所以这也禁止了。哦，还有鱼堰，我们喜欢鱼堰，所以那是第33条，所有鱼堰今后都要从泰晤士河和梅德韦河中彻底清除。那到底是怎么回事？约翰基本上是在过度捕捞还是在偷别人的鱼？那显然是坎特伯雷大主教。他把它放进去是因为他想乘船沿梅德韦河去他的避暑胜地。所以那有点卑鄙。
belonging to another person for castle so that's banned as well oh and fish weirs we love we love the fish weirs so that's article 33 all fish weirs are henceforth to be removed completely from the thames and the medway so what's all that about is john been basically overfishing or stealing other people's fish? That apparently is the Archbishop of Canterbury. He put that in because he wanted to sail up the Medway to his summer resort. So that's a bit sneaky.
基于伦敦标准的标准饮酒量。所以那就在那里。然后你得到著名的，仍然在法典中的两条，这才是真正让《大宪章》在全世界闻名的原因。任何自由民不得被逮捕、监禁、剥夺财产、取缔、流放或以任何方式摧毁。我们也不会反对他，也不会派人反对他，除非经过他同侪的合法判决或根据国家法律。然后下一条，对任何人我们都不会出售，对任何人我们都不会拒绝或拖延权利或正义。从我们的角度来看，我想这就是它的核心。然后还有一大堆关于森林的内容，我们可能会谈到，然后有一个……
Standard drinking measures based on London measurements. So that's there. And then you get the famous, the two famous ones that are still on the statute book, which is really what makes Magna Carta famous across the world. No free man is to be arrested or imprisoned or dispossessed of property or outlawed or exiled or in any way destroyed. Nor will we go against him, nor will we send against him, save by the lawful judgment of his peers or by the law of the land. And then the next one, to no one will we sell sell to no one will we deny or delay right or justice and that's the kind of from our perspective i guess the heart of it um then there's loads of stuff about forests we might come on to that um and then there's a they're
他们显然试图确保约翰不会从这里溜走，所以有很多关于如果约翰违反法律，人们可以提出异议的内容，这显然是约翰根本不想要的，但我猜这显示了他有多么不被信任。有很多关于他的内容，不仅仅是他声称他想去参加十字军东征。
obviously trying to to make sure that john doesn't winkle out of this so there's loads of stuff about how um uh you know if if John is breaking the law, then people can object, which obviously John didn't want at all, but I guess shows how mistrusted he was. There's loads of stuff about him, not just he's claiming that he wants to go on a crusade.
这又是一个骗局。他们试图封锁。有很多关于威尔士人和苏格兰人的内容，这很有趣。所以它被认为是一份英格兰文件，但实际上它是一种英国文件，不是吗？因为它也在处理他们。他们是这场内战的参与者，
This again is a scam. They're trying to block off. There's loads of stuff about the Welsh and the Scots, which is interesting. So it's, you know, it's thought of as an English document, but it's actually a kind of British one, isn't it? Because it's kind of dealing with them as well. They're parties to this sort of civil war,
真的，反对约翰。所以这就是他们在宪章中的存在。是的。然后是一件臭名昭著的事情，后来被从宪章的未来版本中删除了，不是吗？即要有25名男爵来监视约翰。所以这对他的自主权是一个巨大的限制，对吧？他有一个男爵委员会坐在他头上，
really, against John. So that's their presence explained within the chart. Yeah. And then kind of a notorious thing that then gets cut, doesn't it, from future editions of the charter, where there are to be 25 barons to keep watch on John. So that's a huge restraint on his autonomy, right? That he's got this kind of committee of barons sitting over him
为了，什么，为了制衡他？是这样吗？是的，基本上这是一种执行条款，这个委员会将……这是一种执行条款，他们将……这个委员会将会在那里监督宪章的遵守情况，如果约翰不遵守，令他们满意，那么他们在没收他的军事资源方面拥有各种权利，它谈到了拥有他的城堡等等等等。而且我认为
to sort of, what, to hold him in check? Is that the deal? Yes, basically this is a sort of enforcement clause that this council are going a sort of enforcement clause that they this this council are going to sort of be there to sort of monitor observance of the charter and if if john you know doesn't observe it to their um satisfaction then they have all sorts of rights in terms of seizing his military resources and it talks about kind of possessing his castles and so and so forth um and and i think
这是一个，你知道，在某种程度上，这就是意味着这份文件没有很长的保质期，因为它基本上意味着约翰的权力被这个男爵委员会从根本上削弱了，但这也是与过去的事情以及我们可能拥有的这些欧洲先例真正不同的地方，这个男爵委员会似乎与关于等级、忠诚、服从的公认观念有着真正的分歧，这似乎确实是在朝着一个方向发展，即你在说，实际上，你知道，如果金字塔顶端的人没有按照法律统治，他们的权力是可以被制衡的。我可以插一句问一个非常无聊的问题吗？我相信泰德能很快回答。为什么他们不直接杀了约翰？
this is one you know it's one on one level this is one thing that means that this document doesn't have a long shelf life because it it basically means that john john's power is fundamentally undercut by this this council of barons but it's also something that is a real distinction from things that have gone before and these sort of european precedents um that we might have for magna carta this this council of barons seems to be a real divergence from accepted ideas about hierarchy about loyalty about obedience this does seem to be something that is moving in a direction where you're saying, actually, you know, the person at the top of the tree can have their power checked if they're not ruling in accordance with the law. Can I just jump in and ask a very boring question? I'm sure Ted will be able to answer quickly. Why didn't they just kill John?
是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个很好的问题，我没有快速的答案，但我认为，是的，我的意思是，我猜这是一个问题，这不是一场有王位替代候选人的内战，我们谈论的不是玫瑰战争那种有替代候选人作为参与者，互相发动战争的场景。这似乎不是一场有王朝斗争在核心的战争。所以我认为人们并不想，你知道，
Yeah, I mean, I think that's a very good question, which I don't have a quick answer to, but I think, yeah, I mean, I guess it's a question of this isn't a civil war in which alternative claimants to the throne are being, we're not talking war of the roses scenario where alternative kind of claimants are parties that sort of, you know, waging war against each other. This doesn't seem to be one in which, you know, there's a dynastic struggle at the centre of it. And so I don't think it's the sense that people want to, you know,
移除那个王朝并用另一个取代它。但这是关于处理约翰，处理一个糟糕的国王，不想取代君主制，而是如何限制它，如何对其施加限制。但是泰德，接下来发生了什么，所以最后一部分，他们把所有恶意、愤怒和怨恨，
remove that dynasty and replace it with another one. But it is about dealing with, you know, John's, you know, dealing with a bad king, not wanting to, you know, to replace the monarchy, but sort of how to hedge it in, how to sort of place limitations on it. But Ted, what then happens is, so the final kind of section, they took all ill will, indignation and rancor,
从不和时期起在我们之间产生的，我们已经完全免除并赦免了每个人。所以恶意、愤怒、怨恨显然是约翰是什么样的人的总结，但显然他没有坚持下去，一切都出了问题，战争再次爆发，约翰失去了所有的珠宝，在洗涤中还是什么的，穿过河口，有一场大风暴，他死了，据说是因为吃了太多的……因为吃了生苹果酒，新苹果酒和生桃子，是的。就像你做的那样。
which has arisen between us from this time of the discord, we have fully remitted and pardoned to everyone. So the ill will, indignation, rancor is obviously summing up of what John's's like but obviously he doesn't stick to it and it all goes wrong and the war breaks out again john john loses all his what he loses all the jewels in the wash or whatever um crossing the the estuary um and there's a great storm and he dies and teaches he's eaten too many from from eating raw cider, a new cider and raw peaches, yes. As you do.
所以他留下了一个年幼的儿子，亨利三世。但基本上男爵们已经决定要把权力交给法国国王的儿子路易，到约翰去世时，他已经占领了大约一半的国家，不是吗？只有威廉·马歇尔，那位伟大的骑士，到这时已经非常老了，实际上是《大宪章》中贵族名单上第一个被提名的人。
So he leaves behind a young son, Henry III. But basically the barons have decided that they're going to hand it over to the son of the King of France, Louis, who by the time of John's death has seized about half the country, hasn't he? And it's only William Marshall, the great knight, who by this point is very old, and actually is the first person to be named in the list of magnates, in the Magna Carta.
只有多亏了他，他们才能够击败它。他们通过重新发布《大宪章》做到了这一点。如果那没有发生，那么也许《大宪章》会被彻底遗忘。是这样吗？是的，我认为那是对的。而且我认为亨利三世的《大宪章》在关于这份文件的记忆方面是真正关键的。
It's only thanks to him that they're able to defeat it. And they do that by reissuing Magna Carta. And if that hadn't happened, then perhaps Magna Carta would be completely forgotten. Is that right? Yeah, I think that is right. And I think Henry III's Magna Carta is the really critical one in terms of the memory of this document.
所以那是1217年，对吧？1225年。我想你是对的，有一个1217年的版本。因为它和《森林宪章》一起出来，这也非常令人困惑。但我们不会深入讨论，因为那太复杂了。是的，是的，是的，所以，是的，而且我认为那些13世纪和14世纪对《大宪章》的重申对于人们真正记住它至关重要，正如你所说，如果这是一件实际上，你知道，
So that's 1217, isn't it? 1225. I think you're right, there is a 1217 issue. Because that comes out with the Charter of the Forest, which is also very confusing. But we won't get into that because that's too complicated yeah yeah yeah so so yeah and i think those those 13th century kind of um you know and 14th century reiterations of magna carta are critical to people actually remembering it as you as you say if this has been something where actually, you know,
约翰让教皇废除，发布法令说《大宪章》无效，而男爵们决定安装法国国王的儿子，那么也许我们完全忘记了这个例子。是的。我们可能应该休息一下，只是，我的意思是，基本上只是总结一下，并为下半场做准备，我们将谈论《大宪章》的来世，这里有一个来自戈登·史密斯的问题，是《大宪章》的重点在于国王承认他
John gets the Pope to nullify, you know, issue decrees that the Magna Carta is nullified and barons, you know, decide to instead install the son of the King of France, then maybe we completely forget about this instance altogether. Yeah. We should probably have a break, just i mean basically just to sum up and to line up the second half where we'll talk about the you know the afterlife of magna carta here's a question from gordon smith is the point of magna carta that the king recognizes that he
受国家法律的约束，而不是凌驾于法律之上，否则它的意义何在？我的意思是，这本质上是需要记住的关键因素吗？还是我们对此过于浪漫化了？不，我不认为我们是，但我认为这只是其中的一个收获，我认为另一个是，你知道，嗯，有几个，但我认为另一个非常重要的实际上是关于普遍的自由和个人的自由。我认为这是《大宪章》带来的另一个关键点。
is bound by the laws of the land rather than being above them otherwise what is its significance i mean is that essentially the key the key factor to bear in mind or are we being over romantic about that uh no i don't think we are but i think that's i think that's only one of the um takeaways from it i think the other one is you know well there are several but i think another really important one is actually about um liberty in general and and freedom of the individual. And that's another critical thing, I think, that comes from Magna Carta.
哦，那是非常浪漫的文字。不是吗？谈论自由。太棒了。太棒了。以什么作为休息的注脚。非常好。自由。我们很快回来。
Oh, that's very romantic text. Isn't it? Talking about liberty. It's great. It's great. What a note on which to go to a break. Very good. Liberty. We'll see you back soon.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of entertainment.com that'sisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
我们正在谈论《大宪章》。我们已经送走了约翰王。伟大的编年史家马修·帕里斯这样评价他：“尽管地狱本身已经够肮脏了，但约翰的存在让它变得更加肮脏。”希望没人会这样评价《历史余温》和泰德·瓦伦斯在我们播客中的存在。现在，我们已经完成了《大宪章》，完成了约翰，我们要谈谈它的来世，
We're talking about Magna Carta. We have seen off King John. Matthew Paris, the great chronicler, said of him, foul as it is, hell itself is made fouler by the presence of John. Let's hope no one says that about the rest of his history and the presence of Ted Vallance on our podcast. Now, so we've done Magna Carta, we've done John, and we're going to do its afterlife,
我认为这在许多方面是一个更迷人的故事。这是你写了很多关于它的东西，泰德。我们有一个来自西蒙·霍奇的问题。他说，关于《大宪章》的看法在什么时候从关于精英权利转变为更普遍的英格兰权利概念？这种转变有什么价值吗？我想这就是大问题，不是吗？所以当人们今天在报纸上谈论《大宪章》时，你认为他们是在谈论一个基本上在几百年后才发明的虚构的《大宪章》吗？
which I think is in many ways a more fascinating story. It's something that you've written a lot about, Ted. And we've got a question from Simon Hodge. And he says, at what point did the perception of Magna Carta move from being about the rights of an elite to a more generalised conception of English rights? And does that shift have any merit? And I guess that's the big question, isn't it? So when people talk about Magna Carta today in the newspapers, are they talking about an imaginary Magna Carta that was basically invented hundreds of years afterwards, do you think?
我认为他们在某种程度上是在谈论一个虚构的《大宪章》，如果他们是在谈论，你知道，捍卫在封锁期间开放软游乐区的权利，例如。因为那没有被提到，不是吗？那不是法典之一。是的，鱼堰，是的，软游乐区，不。但我们以后可能会回到软游乐区，我希望。但我认为有一些真实的东西，你知道，有一个《大宪章》必须发挥的重要部分，
I think they're to some extent talking about an imaginary Magna Carta, if they're talking about, you know, defending the right to open soft play areas during lockdown, for example. Because that's not mentioned, is it? That's not one of the statutes. Yeah, the fish wears, yes, soft play areas, no. But we might come back to soft play areas, I hope, later on. But I think that there is something genuine um you know that there is a um a genuine uh part the magna carta has to play an important part the magna house the car has to play
在权利和自由观念的发展中延伸到精英之外，这实际上是开始于……你知道，我们可以争辩说它实际上开始于1215年的宪章本身，但肯定是在13世纪和14世纪对《大宪章》的重申中。所以在《大宪章》中，他们谈论的是“自由民”（liber homo），所以显然问题是，谁是不自由的人？有多少人？到什么时候每个英格兰人，我想是英格兰男人而不是女人，是吗？是的。可以被算作自由人。过程是什么？是的。所以，我的意思是，是的，就它被定义为男人而言，那是不变的。虽然，我不知道我们是否
in the development of the idea of um rights and liberties extending beyond the elite and that's something that actually starts um you know we can argue that it actually starts with the 12th 15 charter itself but certainly in the 13th century and on into the 14th century kind of reiterations um of magna carta so in the in the in magna carta they they talk about the free man liber hollow so that obviously the question then is um who are the unfree men? How many are there? And by what point can every Englishman, and I suppose it's Englishmen rather than women, is it? Yes. Be counted as free. What's the process? Yeah. So, I mean, yes, in terms of it being defined as men, that's something that doesn't change. Although, I don't know whether
无论如何都要谈到它，但妇女选举权运动者确实指出，英格兰法律通常使用，你知道，普遍解释阳性代词。所以《大宪章》的权利被视为适用于女性和男性。但13世纪和14世纪发生的事情之一是，宪章语言中这种自由民和不自由民的区别开始被淡化，实际上被抹去了。所以它开始只谈论“人”而不是“自由民”。那些真正令人回味的条款，那些仍然，你知道，今天具有法律效力的条款，开始被赋予这种更普遍的含义。正如我所说，这是在中世纪时期发生的事情。这不是现代的重新发明。
we're going to come on to it anyway, but women's suffrage campaigners did point out that the English law generally uses, you know, interprets masculine pronouns universally. And so Magna Carta rights have been seen to apply to women as well as to men. But one of the things that happens over the 13th and 14th century is this language of this distinction between free and unfree in the language of the charter starts to be watered down and actually obliterated. So it just starts to talk about men instead of free men. those really evocative ones, the ones that are still, you know, have power of law today, come to have this more universal meaning attributed to them. And that's, as I say, that's something that's happening in the medieval period. It's not a modern reinvention.
我们稍后会谈到这一点，但女性选举权运动者确实指出，英国法律通常会普遍解释阳性代词。因此，大宪章所赋予的权利被视为既适用于男性也适用于女性。但在13世纪和14世纪发生的一件事是，宪章中关于自由人与非自由人之间区别的表述开始被淡化，甚至被抹去。它开始只谈论“人”而不是“自由人”。那些真正具有启发意义的条款，即那些至今仍具有法律效力的条款，被赋予了更普遍的含义。正如我所说，这是在中世纪时期发生的，并非现代的重新发明。
It's something that is a part of what's going on with these reissuing confirmations of the charter over the 13th, 14th century. The other thing that's happening as well is it's not just sort of a document that is being, you know, circulated amongst the elite. It's also something that is going out, being confirmed, circulated in courts of law. So it's also got a kind of broader audience to it and a broader kind of reception to it as well, so that it's getting embedded in a broader sense in terms of the national culture.
这是13、14世纪大宪章重新确认过程中所发生的一部分。另一件正在发生的事情是，它不仅仅是一种在精英阶层中流传的文件。它也正在被确认，并在法院中传阅。因此，它也有了更广泛的受众和更广泛的接受度，从而在国家文化的层面上得到了更深层次的植根。
And Teg, also, can I just ask, so Magna Carta blocks off all these wheezes that John has been using to raise money. So is it a coincidence that it's in the decades and then the centuries that follow that you start to get the rise of Parliament and the idea that the King has to turn to Parliament to raise money. So in that sense, is Magna Carta, although it doesn't mention Parliament, could it be considered one of the kind of key influences on the growth of the parliamentary system in England? Yeah, I think so in terms of that, as you say, in that kind of check on, you know, rural power to raise money, which is obviously one of the critical things,
泰德，我还能问一下吗？大宪章阻断了约翰王用来筹集资金的所有诡计。那么，在随后的几十年甚至几个世纪里，议会的兴起以及国王必须求助于议会来筹集资金的观念，这是一种巧合吗？从这个意义上说，虽然大宪章没有提到议会，但它是否可以被视为英国议会制度发展的主要影响因素之一？是的，我认为在某种程度上，正如你所说，它对王权筹集资金的能力形成了一种制约，这显然是至关重要的。
the critical functions of, you know, the medieval and early modern parliament. And one of the things that then comes to be seen as, you know, one of the things that that charter of 1215 is embodying, even as you say, it doesn't actually, you know, use the language of this institution at this stage isn't in existence so yeah and ted um if it's a crucial turning point my sense and maybe i'm wrong is that it comes around about the 17th century when when magna carta really becomes enshrined um as this sort of people start to argue that it's the foundational text of kind of english liberty is that that right? Is it
这是中世纪和近代早期议会的关键职能之一。而1215年的大宪章被视为体现了这一点，尽管正如你所说，它在现阶段并没有使用这种制度的语言，所以它当时并不存在。泰德，如果这是一个关键的转折点，我的感觉是——也许我错了——它大约出现在17世纪，当时大宪章真正被奉为圭臬，人们开始争论它是英国自由的奠基性文本，这是对的吗？是
sort of in the era of the Civil War and the sort of the protectorate and sort of the idea of Magna Carta being linked to the kind of good old course? Am I making that up? No, I think it is incredibly important in the rhetoric of Parliament and those who are resisting Charles I's personal rule, Charles I's government in the 1620s and then during the Civil War in the 1640s. And there was an argument that really Magna Carta is really reinvented in the 17th century, primarily by the English common law jurist Sir Edward Cook, who talks about Magna Carta in these glowing terms as the fountain of all the fundamental laws. So when is he doing that?
在内战时期，在护国公时期，以及大宪章与所谓的“古老事业”联系在一起的观念中吗？我是不是在编造？不，我认为它在议会的言论中，以及在17世纪20年代抵制查理一世个人统治、查理一世政府，以及17世纪40年代内战期间的人们中，都极其重要。有一种观点认为，大宪章在17世纪确实被重塑了，主要是由英国普通法法学家爱德华·科克爵士重塑的，他用极其赞美的词汇将大宪章称为所有根本法的源泉。那么他是什么时候这么做的呢？
So this is in his Institutes, which are posthumously published in 1642, but he's written much earlier. And actually he is himself a victim of raw power in that it's actually Charles I and his government that suppresses the publication of the Institutes because they see it as a kind of politically dangerous text as one that's sort of laying out limitations on raw power. So 1642, the start of the Civil War,
这是在他的《法学总论》中，该书于1642年死后出版，但他写得要早得多。事实上，他本人就是王权的受害者，因为正是查理一世及其政府压制了《法学总论》的出版，因为他们认为这是一种政治上危险的文本，是一种对王权施加限制的文本。所以1642年，内战开始，
and you have a king who, like John, has been resorting to all kinds of taxation wheezes and he was then faced by civil opposition and he loses london yes so were these analogies that were pressing home so there are 1640s there are there are some yeah i mean there are some fairly stark parallels there um uh i, I don't think actually Charles gets compared to John personally that much, although subject to the previous Rest Is History podcast, he was compared to Nero. Oh, the luxurious.
你有一位像约翰王一样的国王，他诉诸各种税收诡计，然后面临民间反对，并失去了伦敦。是的，所以这些类比是在强调这一点吗？所以17世纪40年代，确实有一些相当鲜明的相似之处。嗯，我不认为查理一世真的被拿来和约翰王本人做太多比较，尽管根据之前的《历史余韵》播客，他被比作尼禄。哦，那个奢侈的。
Yes. The luxurious man of taste. Yes, I suppose he was. Yes, exactly, for being a luxurious essay. That's right. So it is very much part of the political discourse of the 1640s. And it's something which is being invoked, I think, in even broader ways in the 1640s too.
是的。那个奢侈的品味之人。是的，我想他是。是的，没错，因为他是一个奢侈的散文家。没错。所以它确实是17世纪40年代政治话语的一部分。而且我认为，在17世纪40年代，它在更广泛的层面上被援引。
So if you look at the way in which the level of john lilburn uses magna carta he starts to talk about magna carta as embodying birthrights so so this is something you know magna carta is basically distilling the innate rights of the englishman the freeborn englishman's rights are, you know, written within Magna Carta. So we kind of get this extension of Magna Carta from, you know, this document into something that is an embodiment of the innate birthrights of the freeborn Englishman. So at that point, people like John Lilburn and the Levellers, so we talked about them, didn't we, Tom, on our Cromwellian podcast. So at that point, are they talking about a Magna Carta that exists in their imagination, basically? I mean, have they read it? Are they aware of all the stuff about the weirs? Or have they just invented this sort of imaginary Magna Carta that they think enshrines this sort of, you know, anti-Norman yoke Anglo-Saxon liberty. But the Norman yoke, I mean, that's separate again, isn't it?
所以如果你看看约翰·利尔伯恩（John Lilburn）使用大宪章的方式，他开始谈论大宪章体现了与生俱来的权利。所以这是某种东西，你知道，大宪章基本上是在提炼英国人与生俱来的权利，自由出生的英国人的权利，你知道，写在大宪章里。所以我们得到了大宪章的这种延伸，从一份文件变成了一种体现自由出生的英国人与生俱来的权利的化身。那么在那个时候，像约翰·利尔伯恩和平均派（Levellers）这样的人——我们谈论过他们，不是吗，汤姆，在我们的克伦威尔播客里。那么在那个时候，他们谈论的是存在于他们想象中的大宪章吗？我的意思是，他们读过它吗？他们知道所有关于诡计的事情吗？还是他们只是发明了这种他们认为体现了某种反诺曼枷锁、盎格鲁-撒克逊自由的虚构大宪章？但诺曼枷锁，我的意思是，那是另一回事，不是吗？
Or is it the same thing? Well, no, they're bound together. And, you know, to answer, you know, your question, Dom, they're not kind of making it up in the sense that Lilburn is getting his Magna Carta from Cook's Institutes, which is, you know, he reads this voraciously as this sort of, you know, text which is detailing all of the rights and liberties that English people enjoy through the common law, Magna Carta being, you know, one of the fundamental
还是同一回事？嗯，不，它们是联系在一起的。而且，为了回答你的问题，多姆，他们并不是在编造，因为利尔伯恩是从科克的《法学总论》中获得他的大宪章的，他如饥似渴地阅读这本书，将其视为一种详细说明了英国人民通过普通法享有的所有权利和自由的文本，大宪章是其中之一。
documents and distillations of this. And he's also taking Cook's view of Magna Carta, which is that Magna Carta is not new law. Magna Carta is a restatement of fundamental laws. Which goes back to the Anglo-Saxon. Yes, absolutely. In his view. Yes, yes. So, you know, this Norman yoke, you know, the conquerors laws that are introduced, Magna Carta is a kind of reaffirmation of those earlier Anglo-Saxon freedoms and liberties. That's the Magna Carta ball.
这是其中的基本文件和精华。而且他还采纳了科克对大宪章的看法，即大宪章不是新法律。大宪章是对根本法的重申。这可以追溯到盎格鲁-撒克逊时期。是的，绝对是。在他看来。是的，是的。所以，你知道，这种诺曼枷锁，征服者引入的法律，大宪章是对那些早期盎格鲁-撒克逊自由和权利的重申。这就是大宪章的本质。
Yes. Because that's clearly not true, is it? I mean, Magna Carta has nothing to do with ancient liberties of Anglo-Saxon free-balling. No, no. But that's also the Magna Carta. Am I not right in thinking, Ted, that that is also the Magna Carta that has gone to america so the americans who are interested in their their sort of intermingled american and english or british history they love magna carta the american bar association paid for you know the sort of runny mead stuff didn't they and they've always been fascinated by that and their magna carta is some ways, it's the 17th century kind of level of Magna Carta rather than the 1215 Weirs Magna Carta. Yeah, yeah, certainly. I mean, I think, yeah, it's the Magna Carta that supposedly guarantees no taxation without representation. It's the Magna Carta that,
是的。因为那显然不是真的，不是吗？我的意思是，大宪章与盎格鲁-撒克逊自由人的古老自由毫无关系。不，不。但那也是大宪章。泰德，我没想错吧，那也是传到美国的大宪章，所以那些对他们那种交织在一起的美国和英国或不列颠历史感兴趣的美国人，他们热爱大宪章。美国律师协会为兰尼米德的那些东西付了钱，不是吗？他们一直对那个很着迷，而他们的大宪章在某种程度上是17世纪那种平均派的大宪章，而不是1215年那些诡计的大宪章。是的，是的，当然。我的意思是，我认为，是的，它是那个据称保证“无代表，不纳税”的大宪章。它是那个
you know, guarantees the rights of representative assemblies. And yeah, definitely not the Magna Carta that's sort of about preventing people from being forced to build bridges. Although, I mean, if an American president forced Americans to build bridges, I'm sure we wouldn't hear the end of it. Getting Magna Carta out for that. Yes, yes.
你知道，保证代议制议会权利的大宪章。是的，绝对不是那种关于防止人们被迫建造桥梁的大宪章。虽然，我的意思是，如果一位美国总统强迫美国人建造桥梁，我相信我们一定会没完没了地听到这件事。为此把大宪章拿出来。是的，是的。
And does it have an... What kind of influence does it have on the idea of a constitution for the americans is does it have any influence at all or is that lurking at the back of their minds yeah i mean i think it's seen as you know a literal influence on on parts of the american constitution um in particular the fifth amendment um and so i mean so that's not giving evidence against yourself, is that right? Yes. You take the Fifth, yeah. Yeah, yeah. And similar kinds of direct influences have been seen
它对美国人的宪法观念有什么影响吗？它有任何影响吗，还是说这只是潜藏在他们的脑海里？是的，我的意思是，我认为它被视为美国宪法某些部分的字面影响，特别是第五修正案。所以，我的意思是，那是不提供不利于自己的证据，对吧？是的。你行使第五修正案权利，是的。是的，是的。类似的直接影响也被观察到
in Universal Declaration of Human Rights and also obviously through their connections to Britain, the Indian Constitution, Canadian Constitution, various other Commonwealth countries, their constitution. So it has had a genuine influence on constitutions across the world and upon important statements of individual rights and liberties. Because you see, Ted, I was so convinced you were going to just come on and say it's all bunk.
在《世界人权宣言》中，当然也通过它们与英国的联系，在印度宪法、加拿大宪法以及其他各种英联邦国家的宪法中。因此，它对世界各地的宪法以及重要的个人权利和自由声明产生了真正的深远影响。因为你看，泰德，我本来非常确信你会直接说这全是胡扯。
But you're going all Wilmsden Churchill. Sorry. English-speaking people. I love it. I love it. Yes. I have it. I've actually got it tattooed on my head.
但你却变得像温斯顿·丘吉尔一样。抱歉。讲英语的人民。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。是的。我有它。我实际上把它纹在了我的头上。
I was to open this shirt. But do you know who he reminds me of? So in the early 80s, Margaret Thatcher gave – Laurence van der Post came to Downing Street, and she showed him around Downing Street, showed him all the busts and stuff. And she said that what she really liked about being British was that if you went into the pub,
我本来要打开这件衬衫。但你知道他让我想起了谁吗？在80年代初，玛格丽特·撒切尔给了——劳伦斯·范德波斯特来到唐宁街，她带他参观了唐宁街，向他展示了所有的半身像之类的东西。她说，她真正喜欢作为英国人的一点是，如果你走进酒吧，
you would hear people talking about Magna Carta and habeas corpus and the rights of the freeborn Englishman. And I never thought I would say this, but Ted is basically Margaret Thatcher in this podcast. So you really... You love all that stuff about individual liberty and it's extraordinary yeah absolutely yeah yeah yeah and what do you think i'll go on set well i was going to say you know i think uh you know as thomas pointed out i um i did spend some time
你会听到人们谈论大宪章、人身保护令以及自由出生的英国人的权利。我从没想过我会这么说，但泰德在这个播客里基本上就是玛格丽特·撒切尔。所以你真的……你热爱所有关于个人自由的东西，这太非凡了。是的，绝对是。是的，是的，你觉得我会怎么说？嗯，我本来想说，你知道，我认为，正如托马斯指出的那样，我确实花了一些时间
on a blog that i no longer keep up sort of talking about magna carta balls and sort of you know and i think some of these kind of anti-lockdown you know um sightings of Magna Carta would fit neatly into that description but I think on you know I also don't want to kind of poo-poo the significance of this document uh either and or you know the the importance of the idea of individual liberty that it that is influenced and that it supports and I think actually if there's one thing to kind of take away from all of the anti-lockdown stuff and i would say first of all just you know i think lockdowns are an important public health measure that have had to be put in place but i think there is an important thing underneath this which is actually um what limitations are there on on the executive power in the UK to do certain things that it deems to be necessary in an emergency?
在一个我不再维护的博客上谈论大宪章的本质，你知道，我认为其中一些反封锁的、对大宪章的“目击”会很贴切地归入这种描述。但我认为，我也并不想贬低这份文件的重要性，或者它所影响和支持的个人自由理念的重要性。而且我认为，实际上，如果说要从所有的反封锁事件中吸取什么教训的话——首先，我认为封锁是一项重要的公共卫生措施，必须实施——但我认为这背后有一件重要的事情，那就是英国行政部门在紧急情况下做某些它认为必要的事情时，到底有什么限制？
And this is something that's come up before in terms of statutes, you know, Defence of the Realm Acts during the two world wars and how those impinged upon individual liberties. And, you know, what are the barriers to a government doing that basically well because the anonymous of bethune make fabulous okay anonymous chronicler who rode in the the train of whatever it was the duke of bethune or whatever uh said of king john that he was a very bad man and whenever he could he told lies rather than the truth so i guess the key to magna carter is to try and stop bad men who tell lies rather than the truth from having their evil way that would be that would be the the enduring perspective of magna carta and perhaps you know in in 2021 that's just as important as it was in in 1215 you can say yeah yeah absolutely yeah so the the um we've looked at the influence of Magna Carta on America
这在法规方面以前也出现过，你知道，两次世界大战期间的《国土防卫法》，以及它们如何影响个人自由。而且，你知道，政府这样做的障碍是什么？基本上，因为贝蒂讷的匿名者写了很棒的记录，那个骑在贝蒂讷公爵随从里的匿名编年史作者说约翰王是一个非常坏的人，只要有机会，他就会撒谎而不是说真话。所以我猜大宪章的关键在于试图阻止那些撒谎而不是说真话的坏人随心所欲。这将是大宪章持久的视角，也许在2021年，这和1215年一样重要。你可以说，是的，是的，绝对是。所以，我们研究了大宪章对美国的影响
and on various Commonwealth countries, but what about Britain itself? So what's the kind of line of inheritance that takes us from the 17th century through to 2021 and the use of Magna Carta in lockdown disputes? Yeah, yeah. I mean, it still has a – think it's it's got so embedded partly as a result of this, you know, enormous discussion in the 17th century, but also, you know, as a result of its late medieval circulation, it's got so embedded in kind of, you know, the English kind of historical memory that is continuing to be invoked by radical figures in the 18th century. So John Wilkes refers to it in his campaigns for press freedom. And it also gets invoked by radical movements in the late 18th and early 19th century.
以及对各个英联邦国家的影响，但英国本身呢？那么，从17世纪到2021年，以及在封锁争议中使用大宪章，这种传承路线是什么？是的，是的。我的意思是，它仍然有一种——我认为它已经如此根深蒂固，部分原因是17世纪那场巨大的讨论，但也因为中世纪晚期的流传，它在英国的历史记忆中已经如此根深蒂固，以至于18世纪的激进人物仍在不断援引它。约翰·威尔克斯在争取新闻自由的运动中就提到了它。它在18世纪末和19世纪初的激进运动中也被援引。
So the London Corresponding Society members refer to Magna Carta as giving them the sort of authority for their campaigns for manhood suffrage, and the same with the Chartists on into the 19th century. And I think there's a few things here that are going on here. One is actually just the sort of the prominence of Magna Carta as a constitutional document as a reference point. But the other thing is actually also rhetorically the value of something like Magna Carta. And I think this is something you can see in modern invocations of it as well, that Magna Carta is a really useful reference point if you want to say, I'm arguing for these rights, and they are my rights anyway, because I am a freeborn Englishman, or I am a freeborn Englishman or I am a British citizen.
所以伦敦通讯协会的成员提到大宪章赋予了他们争取男性普选权的权威，宪章运动者在19世纪也是如此。我认为这里发生了一些事情。一是大宪章作为宪法文件作为参考点的突出地位。但另一件事实际上是像大宪章这样的东西在修辞上的价值。我认为这是你在现代对它的援引中也能看到的一点，即如果你想说“我正在为这些权利辩护，而且无论如何它们都是我的权利，因为我是自由出生的英国人，或者我是英国公民”，大宪章是一个非常有用的参考点。
So you don't have to say, I need these things because the French revolutionaries are arguing for them. And, you know, therefore, you know, run risk of being declared unpatriotic or run risk of being declared responsible for the terror or, you know, any of those other things, you can paint yourself as a good, authentic, John Bull, you know, traditionalists in arguing for these things because these things are embodied in Magna Carta. So it's a really useful, I think, rhetorical tool has been over centuries for movements for kind of political reform and constitutional change. Because it was the kind of intersection point between David Davis and Tony Benn, wasn't it? What was it? There was 48 day detention? 48 days detention, yes. That was under the Blair government?
所以你不必说，我需要这些东西是因为法国革命者在为它们辩护。而且，因此，冒着被宣布为不爱国或被宣布为对恐怖负责的风险，你可以把自己描绘成一个好的、地道的、约翰牛式的传统主义者来为这些事情辩护，因为这些东西体现在大宪章中。所以我认为，几个世纪以来，它对于政治改革和宪法变革运动来说，一直是一个非常有用的修辞工具。因为它曾是戴维·戴维斯和托尼·本之间的交汇点，不是吗？那是什么？那是48天拘留？48天拘留，是的。那是在布莱尔政府时期？
Yes, yes. And was it, you know, invoked to sort of, you know, the ushering in the death of Magna Carta, which again is, you know, again is an interesting kind of historical echo because very similar things are said about the revocation of habeas corpus in the late 18th and early 19th centuries, partly in reaction to the activities of groups like the London Corresponding Society. And do you think with Brexit and perhaps the withdrawal from European Court of Justice and all that kind
是的，是的。而且它是否被援引来预示大宪章的死亡，这又是一个有趣的某种历史回声，因为在18世纪末和19世纪初，在对伦敦通讯协会等团体的活动做出反应时，人们对废除人身保护令也说了类似的话。你认为随着英国脱欧，也许还有退出欧洲法院等等，
of thing, will the significance of Magna Carta as a kind of totem of English justice and liberty increase again, do you think? Yes, I think that has sort of, you know, heightened the emphasis upon it again, because of this sort of sense in which this is something that is uniquely ours and it's not you know we're not kind of invoking some kind of airy fairy concept of natural rights or you know universal nonsense liberty it's all weird these are these are these are real you know proper concerns yeah i border yeah I think we I think we've basically done
大宪章作为英国正义和自由图腾的意义会再次增加吗？是的，我认为这再次加强了对它的强调，因为人们有一种感觉，即这是我们独有的东西，我们不是在援引某种虚无缥缈的自然权利概念或普遍的无意义的自由，这些都是真实的、适当的关切。是的，我认为我们基本上已经完成了。
I think we have done it I've just got one last question so there are four there are four copies of it
我想我们已经完成了。我还有一个最后的问题，所以有四个副本
so there's no there's no one kind of master version is that they were just loads that were all of equal status and they all got
所以没有一个主版本，它们只是很多地位平等的副本，它们都被
sent out perhaps to cathedrals or whatever so there are there are two in the British Museum British Library two in the British Library museum british library two in the british library one in lincoln and one in salisbury which is the best so which is the best and why is it well i think tom i should i should let you argue that argue that point yeah it's salisbury guys
送到了大教堂或其他地方，所以大英博物馆有两个，大英图书馆有两个，林肯有一个，索尔兹伯里有一个，哪个是最好的？哪个是最好的，为什么？嗯，我想汤姆，我应该让你来争论这一点。是的，是索尔兹伯里的，伙计们。
i've seen the lincoln one i think the lincoln is the lincoln one not the oldest have i made that up yeah they're all the same i mean i think it Lincoln... Is the Lincoln one not the oldest? Have I made that up? Yeah. They're all the same. I think it's definitely Lincoln. No, I think it's... There we go. I think the question is...
我见过林肯的那份，我觉得林肯的那份不是最古老的吗？我是不是编造的？是的，它们都一样。我的意思是，我认为林肯……林肯的那份不是最古老的吗？我是不是编造的？是的。它们都一样。我想肯定是林肯。不，我想是……好了。我想问题是……
I think the question is in Salisbury. Tom, the question is in Salisbury. Ted is the expert and Ted is the same. Lincoln, what I will grant to Lincoln is it's had the most interesting afterlife. Because I think it got sent to America during the Second World War. Yeah, I think that's right. It was sent to Canada. Was it America?
我想问题是在索尔兹伯里。汤姆，问题是在索尔兹伯里。泰德是专家，泰德说的是一样的。林肯，我承认林肯的一点是，它有着最有趣的来世。因为我认为它在第二次世界大战期间被送到了美国。是的，我想那是对的。它被送到了加拿大。是美国吗？
Yeah. And he got stuck there, I think, and kind of ended up in Australia and he just made it back to Lincoln by the skin of his teeth. What a happy story. What a story of terrible jeopardy and a nice resolution.
是的。而且它被困在那里，我想，最后到了澳大利亚，它差点就回不到林肯了。多么快乐的故事。多么一个充满可怕危险和美好结局的故事。
But the one in Salisbury has been there the whole way through. So in a sense, it's the most true-born... I see. All right, stop it. So I think that's a good note on which to end
但索尔兹伯里的那份一直都在那里。所以从某种意义上说，它是最纯正的……我明白了。好了，停下。所以我认为这是一个很好的结束语。
thank you so much for coming on and putting us right about Magna Carta so we have decided Magna Carta did not die in vain and
非常感谢你来这里，纠正我们对大宪章的认识，所以我们决定大宪章没有白死，并且
thank you to Ted and we will see you all next time for another fascinating glimpse of history goodbye bye bye history. Goodbye. Bye-bye.
感谢泰德，我们下次再见，去了解另一个迷人的历史片段。再见，再见，历史。再见。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史余韵》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。